vous dites je vais être une actrice
porno quoi vous avez 14 ans quoi
vous connaissez tout le monde ça va
ouais ça va connaissez Élie François
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est génial je peux refaire quatre
heures là je suis sur le pot c'est
génial pas mal c'est un peu cher mais
j'espère que les prix vont baisser parce
que ça peut te sauver la vie en scooter
c'est génial donc au moment où tu tombes
tu tires parce que ça accroché ça
accroche un crochet j'ai inventé ça il y
a deux mois j'ai bricolé ça dans mon
garage et voilà je lance le produit on
va voir après si ça marche pas comment
ça va
super
et après une carrière de deux ans dans
le cinéma porno et 70 films X en deux
ans
vous avez décidé d'arrêter et d'écrire
un livre pour expliquer comment une
femme peut en venir au porno voilà alors
ce livre s'appelle j'assume il est
publié chez Scali et il sort en ce
moment voilà et vous raconter votre
votre histoire vous êtes né en 1981 à
Villecresnes dans le 94 tu connais toi
pas du tout tu habites pas dans un coin
comme ça TOI non oui
dans le 95 ouais
excuse-moi ensuite vous grandissez à
mi-sur-seine dans le 77
très beau département et voilà Laurent
ma fille mesdames messieurs alors votre
père beau brun cadre à la SNCF votre
mère jolie blonde coiffeuse voilà jusque
là tout va bien jusque là tout va bien
mais quand vos parents se séparent le
nouveau copain de votre mère vient
habiter chez vous là ça va déjà moins
bien et votre père lui il vous présente
à chaque fois une une fille nouvelle je
sais pas vous le voyez alors pour vous
c'est quand même pas drôle du tout
évidemment et vous vous réfugiez dans la
bouffe à 13 ans vous pesez 85 kg quand
même
et quand votre père se marie vous passez
à 92 kg ça c'était les repas de noces
c'est toujours très
lourdes si ce serait passé vraiment
comme ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt les dégâts parce que tout le
monde divorce à tour de bras mais enfin
voilà quand même les dégâts du truc quoi
92 kg hein voilà alors vous décidez de
maigrir toute seule vous perdez 15 kilos
en 3 mois ce qui est vachement bien et
puis à ce moment-là vous arrêtez
complètement de vous nourrir et quand
vous mangez s'il vous arrive de manger
quand vous avez par exemple dans votre
famille je suis votre grand-mère vous
faites vomir après fallait que je fasse
croire à ma mère que je mangeais
normalement et bon j'allais expédier la
nourriture des
dès que je pouvais quoi dès que j'avais
un moment alors là vous commencez un
petit peu à contrôler votre poids et
vous décidez de vous taper tous les mecs
systématiquement tous les mecs qui vous
calculez pas
ou les mecs défis qui qui vous faisaient
chier quoi
à l'époque vous coucher pas vous vous
portez
et c'est là alors voilà aussi un des
problèmes du monde moderne c'est là
qu'un jour avec des copines vous décidez
de mater un film porno vous avez quel
âge à ce moment-là
moi
c'était une baise je me suis créée un
personnage que j'appelais Chanel dans
mon dans mon imagination donc c'était
mon double et donc c'était une espèce de
brune mince mon opposé ce que je n'étais
pas et lorsque je suis tombé sur un film
X la première fois j'ai vu cette nana
qui ressemblait étrangement à mon
personnage et quand j'ai vu la tronche
de mes potes devant ce film je me suis
dit ah ouais c'est ça le pouvoir c'est
sexe
et là vous décidez de devenir une
actrice porno vous dites je vais être
une actrice porno quoi vous avez 14 ans
quoi ouais j'ai 14 ans
14 ans
c'est terrible cette scène dans votre
bouquin avec un manche de fourche qui
est en fait une décoration de la cuisine
de votre mère vous mettez un préservatif
sur le manche de fourche je connaissais
pas l'existence des objets sexuels tels
que les godmichet etc et donc je
trouvais que cette fourche ressemblait
étrangement peut-être un sexe masculin
et je me suis dit plutôt que de donner
ma virginité un connard je vais la
prendre moi-même vous décidez de vous
dépuceler vous-même et là vous voulez
devenir une pro du sexe alors vous
mettez tous les films possibles vous
vous entraînez à faire des fellations
avec des sucettes puis un moment vous
passez vraiment au travaux pratiques
avec des vrais garçons et là vous mettez
du Nutella parce que quand même
une espèce d'étudiante en sexe
je pense vraiment pas que j'étais très
j'étais pas une femme et sexuelle je
pense vraiment je voulais apprendre à
cette époque mais vraiment savoir
et j'ai fait une erreur de s'éduquer au
porno
ça bouleversé ma sexualité quand même
faut savoir ne passer du quai à ça quoi
de prendre comme un divertissement
vous êtes en mini-jupe talent et vous
chassez les mecs dans dans les pubs
jusqu'au jour vous tombez amoureuse d'un
certain Christophe et là c'est une
déception parce que finalement il vous
plante quoi il sent il s'en va il vous
laisse tomber hein
auparavant
et là vous dites les mecs c'est fini à
jamais quoi ouais et là je me jure de ne
plus jamais tomber amoureuse et d'être
très glacial avec c'est le contraire qui
va vous arriver à ce moment-là vous
tombez sur Farid un cahier de la cité
macho brutal qui vous fait participer à
des orgies incroyables dans des caves de
cité c'est insensé ce que vous racontez
dans votre bouquin c'est assez délicat
on
je le connaissait bien et un soir on se
revoit donc on va dans sa cave on se
fume un pétard
de Nana débarque avec un mec et bon
c'était une partie de plaisir au début
il me fait une caméra il m'a dit bah si
amuse-toi film ok c'est cool moi je vois
les nanas qui sont contentes elles
commencent à coucher avec les mecs tout
se passe bien quoi sauf qu'à un moment
donné les mecs vont un peu trop loin et
ça dégénère dans le viol et là vous vous
sentez très mal
alors ce Farid vous bat régulièrement et
vous vous enfoncez dans l'anorexie vous
passez au laxatif vous êtes devenu une
accro au laxatif et là alors vous avez
20 ans ce qui est pas ce qui est pas
vieux vous tombez enceinte et subitement
vous êtes là vous dites pour les besoins
de l'enfant vous décidez de faire du
porno voilà il se casse à ma au moment
où j'accouche et c'était un homme qui
qui était interdit bancaire donc tout
était sur mon compte j'ai eu énormément
de dettes je me suis retrouvée très vite
dans une galère terrible à ne me priver
moi nourriture m'acheter Katia yaourt
par semaine pour nourrir moi et tout
laisser pour mon gamin et là je me suis
dit j'ai pas 50 solutions encore il me
faut de l'argent très vite et cache de
votre mot vous avez un euro 50 pour lui
faire un cadeau donc vous vous dites
voilà faut que je fasse un boulot et
vous souvenez que vous rêviez des
actrices de porno quand vous aviez 12
ans vous prenez ça comme métier ça vous
redonne confiance en Vous finalement de
faire ce boulot ouais je crois que le
porno moi ça m'a vraiment
[Musique]
ça m'a sauvé quoi je dirais que le porno
m'a sauvé je sais que ça a détruit
beaucoup de filles moi je dirais que ça
m'a vraiment sauvé ça m'a ça m'a fait
grandir ça m'a rendu plus forte ça m'a
sorti de la merde dans laquelle j'étais
parce que Dieu sait que j'étais bien et
non je suis très je suis très contente
quoi mon métier je l'ai fait de façon
très professionnelle j'ai jamais fait ce
que j'avais pas envie de faire je suis
imposé le préservatif tout au long de ma
carrière et ça a été ma plus grande
fierté
là vous devenez une espèce de petite
star du porno sous le nom de Nina
Roberts vous faites la Une de votre
vidéo vous en faites une autre vous
faites un remake de Pretty Woman
et vous vivez ça assez bien apparemment
pourquoi vous êtes arrêté alors
pour plusieurs raisons
lorsque j'ai débuté dans le porno j'ai
annoncé ça à ma maman
je lui ai fait trois promesses la
première de toujours tourner avec un
pote la seconde de ne jamais faire des
scores et de ne jamais toucher au
drogues dures et la troisième d'arrêter
ma carrière au bout de deux ans quoi
qu'il arrive au sommet je voulais pas le
problème c'est que c'est
on peut pas tourner 5 ans une actrice de
X bon on est obligé de d'être renouvelé
un peu partout
j'avais accepté de jouer le jeu quoi un
problème c'est qu'au bout de tant
d'années on vous a vu dans énormément de
films donc on vous appelle moins vous
coûter moins cher je voulais pas en
arriver là quoi il est vraiment quitter
ça au sommet de ma carrière ce que j'ai
fait vous arrêtez deux ans après et
alors quand même au moment où vous
arrêtez au moment de la dernière scène
vous dites je me sens dans la peau d'une
prostituée donc c'est quand même que
c'est beaucoup moins gai que ce que vous
racontez là quand même ma dernière scène
fut terrible parce que tout au long de
ma carrière je n'avais personne j'étais
célibataire donc c'est très facile vous
débranchez votre cerveau vous arrivez
sur un tournage vous tournez vous
rentrez vous prenez votre argent j'étais
tombée amoureuse
là c'est terrible quand vous aimez un
homme et qu'il va falloir vous donner un
autre c'est Iggy ouais je lave les fois
vous vous donniez un autre alors vous
aimez un mec et vous en avez qu'un dans
la tête c'est pas possible pas pour moi
en tout cas
là c'était plus du tout possible se
termine très mal aux pulsions violentes
contre les gens avec qui vous vous
tournez vous leur en voulez j'arrivais à
lui sourire parce que j'étais consciente
qui était pour rien mais je m'imaginais
en train de l'étrangler lui arracher les
tripes et lui dire ça le porc enfin je
l'insulte et tous les noms dans ma tête
quoi et là vous rentrez chez vous vous
prenez à peu près une quinzaine de
douches
faites un jeune pour vous pour vous
purifier un petit peu après le porno je
m'étais toujours juré qu'à ma dernière
scène je me purifierai quoi et le corps
et l'intérieur et l'extérieur vous allez
faire quoi maintenant Lina
alors j'ai pour projet c'est un projet
d'écrire un second bouquin que je
voulais appeler la religion citée en
dénonçant
la mentalité des jeunes des quartiers
ce sera romancé
et autrement je commence à faire un peu
de casting dans le cinéma dit
traditionnel je me fais pas d'illusion
je suis pas folle mais bon ça peut être
amusant qu'on va dire ça me divertit
pour l'instant
voilà ça s'appelle j'assume c'est publié
aux éditions Scali avec beaucoup de
filles qui écoutent et qui voudraient
avoir des des conseils sur l'amour
prédire
[Musique]
comment fait-on pour bien simuler un
organe
alors pour bien simuler un orgasme
c'est dingue
je pense qu'il faut y croire d'abord
et comme le faire en anglais parce que
j'ai peut-être un plan
juste comme ça ça me donne les clés
comment on fait pour bien simuler un
organe sérieux
je pense qu'il faut trembler j'y crois
un peu les mecs
a souvent des orgasmes
c'est mon cas moi j'en sais rien moi je
sais que ça me tend les muscles ça me
crispe un peu les nerfs et donc quand ça
relâche ça tremble
je suis tombée sur une épileptique dis
donc
ça c'est des questions intéressantes
qu'est-ce que ça fait en plus une double
pénétration
une double pénétration alors moi sur les
tournages j'ai jamais pris le plaisir à
faire ce genre de pratique en revanche
d'après mes collègues donc il y a une
façon de le faire ce qui est une espèce
de nerf entre l'anal et le vagin qu'il
faut chatouiller en faisant ça le
problème c'est que si vous rentrez les
deux en même temps ça pince le nerf et à
ce moment là ça peut être très
désagréable quelle est la position la
moins fatigante pour faire l'amour
c'est ta femme c'est un message reçu je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire tout de
suite
moteur si tu peux annoncer la DIV de
l'auberge espagnole sur France 2 mardi
14 c'est cool bises Astrid
on le regardera
la position la moins fatiguante pour
faire l'amour alors le missionnaire le
missionnaire a à partir de quelle taille
peut-on traiter un mec de petite [__]
je crois que les normes c'est entre 13
et 14 c'est ça on est
écoutez
le début du vagin et vraiment la partie
la plus sensible donc ça sert à rien
d'avoir un sexe sur au Maroc
12 cm je sais pas je vais être gentil
elle est gentille
devant leur télé
réveille-toi
tu es en train de regarder
est-ce que le sperme est bon pour la
peau non ah bon
la recommandez pas à vous non et surtout
pas dans les yeux oui parce que dans les
yeux
ça lui rappelle toute sa jeunesse
je te dis Nina dans son livre elle a
raison c'est que tout le monde met des
capotes dans le cinéma porno mais les
éjacs faciales ça peut rentrer dans
l'oeil et puis l'oeil est une des
parties du corps qui n'est pas protégé
par des muqueuses et c'est le sida c'est
tout de suite quoi
elle a raison on devrait faire l'amour
avec des lunettes de ski et un fait une
doudoune
on sait jamais voilà ah oui est-ce que
le goût du sperme change d'un garçon
ah oui les garçons ont tous des goûts
différents
enfin il y a des trucs qui font que moi
je sais que certains harder prennent du
blanc mange beaucoup de blanc d'oeuf
pour avoir pas mal de sperme bon parce
que c'est quand même très visuel on est
porno je sais que des mecs sous
antibiotiques le sperme peut avoir un
goût absolument
aiguilles quand on fait l'amour
crever son canapé en cuir
quelle technique permet de faire ce
qu'on veut de l'homme avec lequel on est
moi j'irai va rester déjà soi-même et ne
pas avoir de tabou finalement quand on
s'aime rien n'est sale
je pense que
oui tout tout type de de plaisir sexuel
c'est à partir du moment où les deux
personnes sont consentantes c'est pas je
pense que ça
déjà ça lui évite d'aller voir ailleurs
lui demander des trucs comment oui c'est
une question qui intéresse beaucoup nos
amis téléspectatrices comment peut-on
refuser poliment une sodomie en disant
non merci déjà
vous feriez quoi si votre mec avait une
panne un jour
et que j'en ai vraiment envie je me
branle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu